by the time help arrived it was too late
for many who lived here including
children
but even after the last body was found
neighbors continue to dig through the
rubble in the hope of salvaging what
they can
the residents described what happened
all of a sudden i just saw the bulk of
mud and palm trees uprooted from the
stump the mud which fell destroyed these
three houses which caused the death of
six people
the destruction
also leaving many here homeless
we live here because this is where we
manage to pay cheaper rent i don't have
the money to pay for an expensive house
emergency workers say two more people
were killed in freetown as a result of
the torrential rains
an evacuation order has now been issued
so our presence here today with epa and
other agencies is to actually continue
assessing the risks around and advise
other
households within this area to
voluntarily indicate whilst the ndma and
other agencies work modalities in place
to get the other hand in boulders down
so that we could prevent them for that
disaster president julius madabio issued
a statement sending condolences to
affected families
he once described sierra leone as the
world's third most vulnerable nation
when it comes to the impact of climate
change
yet despite a government ban five years
ago people continue to build settlements
in disaster-prone areas in and around
freetown
as seen here the consequences can be
fatal mohammed idris al jazeera